[Música]
sácatela no lo sabes es una Pepita que
pierde tu tiempo para nada sacarte tu
cabecita antes de volverte loquito y yo
te digo sácatela manos Muchas gracias
por compartir este momento con nosotros
en 24 Gracias
actualmente de gira por latinoamérica y
justamente el último disco de la Banda
teatro está en español cuéntanos Cómo
surgió este disco y cómo se compuso
desde hace unos años cuando estamos de
gira por España y Sudamérica empezamos a
escribir cada vez más canciones en
español especialmente Sacha que en algún
momento salió con una chica española Así
que escribió un montón de canciones y en
un momento dado nos dijimos tenemos que
hacer un álbum no podíamos ponerlas en
cada álbum como la canción jardín y así
hicimos este álbum Sacha se encargaba
más de la parte tradicional y de
canciones y yo me encargaba más de la
parte reguetón electro Así que es una
mezcla de todo sé que entiendo el
español pero lo hablo mal Así que me
resultó más complicado para las letras
por lo que pedí ayuda a la gente trabajé
con Tatiana hazstel para la canción y tú
te vas por ejemplo que es un artista
estadounidense Mexicana con mucho
talento y a veces íbamos mucho más allá
por ejemplo para la canción teatro
lúcido en la que en realidad estaba
esperando el fiaturing de residente que
después de dos meses todavía no me había
dado el material así que me dije bueno
voy a intentarlo Yo rápidamente y para
reírme un poco puse la letra de la fem
en Google translation la traduje al
español puse la voz y luego escuché la
voz de Google en español y la grabé y
luego modifiqué la voz para hacer notas
con ella así que por eso teatro lúcido
es la voz de Google en español por
ejemplo que canta Así que es divertido
Hay un montón de pequeñas cosas como
esas y luego Durante los conciertos
sientes que tener canciones en español
es algo que te permití conectar con el
público por ejemplo durante esta gira
cantan más canciones en español Es
verdad que me digo que aunque a nuestro
entorno a la gente con la que trabajamos
les encanta decir que hagáis un disco en
español no significa que lo vayan a
escuchar los hispanohablantes he visto
que ayuda mucho para los conciertos
porque todo el mundo puede cantar al
unísono y también es Guay porque en
Francia la gente es menos propensa
cantar Nuestras canciones en español y
aquí las cantan así que es muy bonito
y hay algún artista que les inspira a ti
o hasta allá de latinoamérica
por ejemplo y también el ska cubano que
escuchaba de pequeño y luego la Cumbia
en general
cuando intentamos entender cuál es el
estilo musical de la fama surgen varias
expresiones
ecléctico laboratorio musical pero leí
un comentario en YouTube pago uno de sus
vídeos que no hablaba de estilo sino de
estado de ánimo es algo que te parece
acertado
sí hay un estado de ánimo y de hecho lo
veo en nuestros aficionados en general
tenemos unos fans muy lindos y nuestros
fans se llevan bien entre ellos y es
verdad que es un estado de ánimo tenemos
un público bastante bueno sano puro y
genial en general Cuando sabes que un
chico le gusta la fem significa que le
gusta reír le gusta la cultura le gusta
el pasado le gusta la historia le gustan
los 60 a los 80 y también va a ser
alguien que no acepta necesariamente los
canales de masas dominantes y que va a
ir a buscar y que tiene curiosidad Así
que obviamente es gente muy espabilada
también hay una cosa que sale a menudo
cuando leemos sus entrevistas es tu
deseo de hacer música que envejezca bien
Y es cierto que sería ineficiente dar
sus canciones o sus discos
no sabemos datarlas
porque es esto tan importante para ti
es un producto de calidad para mí es
importante hacer un producto de calidad
como cuando ves los edificios antiguos
de París por lo general aguantan bien
llevan ahí 200 años mientras que hoy en
día las construcciones modernas no
aguantan más de 20 años y hay que romper
los edificios Así que es como fabricar
lavadoras que aguanten bien fabricar
productos de calidad Es realmente eso
este lado atemporal se percibe en todos
sus videoclips y también en su película
ya que estrenaron una película llamada
paradigmas para el tercer álbum como
surgió lo de grabar y estrenar una
película fue un proceso de un montón de
ideas estúpidas en primer lugar
realmente hacía mucho tiempo que
queríamos hacer una película entonces un
día Tuvimos una reunión con un tipo de
una discográfica que nos dijo que había
hecho todos sus vídeos supuestamente
haciendo una película que había
presentado un expediente para conseguir
una mega subvención y que consiguió una
mega subvención Así que se nos ocurrió
hacer eso porque estábamos buscando
financiación para el videoclip de la
canción paradigma Sabiendo que teníamos
que construir un plato de televisión
porque para nosotros esta canción era un
gingle de televisión Así que nos dijimos
vale tenemos que construir un plato de
televisión pero pensamos Bueno sí
tenemos que hacer un plato de televisión
nos va a costar un poco de dinero solo
por un clip Después tendremos que hacer
un espectáculo con él así que por qué no
hacer un programa en YouTube y tocar
varias canciones Y entonces el tipo nos
dijo si hacen varios clips pueden
conseguir una mega subvención excepto
que al final no teníamos suficiente
dinero para todos esos clips Así que la
película nos costó 100.000 euros fue
todo el dinero que ahorramos de los
conciertos y que invertimos en ella al
final no conseguimos la subvención
porque no cumplíamos Los criterios pero
Fue divertido todo y de hecho paladín
Era realmente un álbum conceptual raro
el disco ya estaba ahí y luego tuvimos
que hacer una película sobre él así que
solo hicimos bobadas de última hora Así
que intentamos hacer malabarismos para
que tuviera sentido y a veces lo tiene Y
a veces son tonterías de última hora
pero al final es una obra de arte que se
mantiene en pie y es muy chévere
atemporal y va contracorriente de todo
lo que se hace ahora Así que es cool ya
sabes
y luego la película está disponible en
internet
sí está gratis en YouTube para mí era
importante porque formo parte de la
generación que descubrió YouTube tarde y
se formó en YouTube no puedo con Spotify
cosas de streaming y antes de que
existieran las plataformas de streaming
escribías películas gratis en YouTube y
veías películas realmente cutres y para
nosotros tenía sentido hacer la película
así y sobre todo porque la película no
estaba hecha realmente de forma
profesional pues adelante la publicamos
en YouTube
sin embargo hubo proyecciones verdad
porque la película está gratis en
YouTube y apenas tuvo 70.000 visitas y
para nosotros eso no es mucho así que
por eso en retrospectiva estamos un poco
tristes de Haber puesto tanta energía en
las películas de poner tanto dinero y
que al final a la gente no le importe la
gente quiere ver dos o tres vídeos como
máximo mientras que para nosotros era
una forma de ser generosos y devolver
algo de expresar nuestra visión etcétera
Así que finalmente tenemos que
dedicarnos más a la música
justamente tienen un universo visual muy
rico muy desarrollado pero en el
escenario durante esta gira sorpresa
vemos a los siete miembros y sus
disfraces y sus instrumentos no hay
pantallas o decorado
que en realidad cuesta dinero No te
engañes es mucho dinero lo hacemos
cuando actuamos en grandes salas en
Francia o para algunos conciertos cuando
queremos divertirnos por ejemplo tenemos
hologramas tenemos una mano de neón pero
es tanto dinero porque después tienes
que comprar los decorados contratar a la
gente para que cuide de los decorados y
los instale Así que eso significa pagar
al menos a dos tres cuatro cinco seis
personas más Hay que darles de comer
pagarles el hotel el transporte si
añades 10 personas para instalar los
decorados necesitas un autobús más la
gente no se da cuenta pero un autobús
cuesta entre 2000 y 3000 € al día así
que nos estamos desarrollando Aunque
perdamos dinero viniendo a Sudamérica lo
hacemos gracias a los conciertos que
hacemos en Francia Así que si
quisiéramos traer de vuelta todos los
visuales tendríamos que estar en la
etapa en la que tocamos en estadios cosa
que me encantaría hacer y por eso
estamos trabajando duro ahora y espero
que dentro de 10 años podamos empezar a
tocar en estadios Y entonces será
realmente una locura verás una especie
de cabeza de mujer de 20 metros con ojos
blancos y pelo largo bajando y luego al
final del pelo nos veremos jugando
Entonces ella abrirá la boca y habrá
humo y luego no sé saldremos en tirolina
Pues ahí lo tienes pero es algo que
realmente tendrán que venir a ver más
adelante por eso a veces hay gente que
dice Bueno la banda era underground
ahora es mainstream en realidad es solo
una evolución y Cuanto más dinero
tengamos mejor será para la banda Porque
podremos expresar aún más nuestra visión
de 360 grados e Imagínate si tuviéramos
el presupuesto de una película de Tim
Burton o de Star Wars llegaríamos mucho
más lejos llegarían fantasmas voladores
en plan Harry Potter tendríamos
persecuciones en rolls-royce No sé cosas
chéveres de todas formas necesitamos
tener más recursos estamos creciendo
poco a poco estoy muy orgulloso de los
progresos que hemos hecho cuando veo que
13 años después ya tenemos disfraces
somos capaces de tocar para 800.000 2000
personas
mil personas completo además
completo Sí normalmente cuando vas a un
país nuevo sueles ir a locales con 200
personas bares pequeños Así que paso a
paso desgraciadamente Con nuestra música
elegimos el camino más difícil porque no
es la música más accesible y mainstream
entrar en el mundo del mainstein con
este tipo de música es mucho más difícil
pero espero que lo consigamos y estaría
muy orgulloso de estar en los canales
principales con este tipo de música
porque la varia el cerebro de la gente
con música de buena calidad y no con
mala música
en cualquier caso incluso cines
escenografía al menos en esta gira
sentimos que hay una verdadera
transformación entre los videoclips los
álbumes de estudio y el escenario se
siente que cuando vamos a verles en
concierto es cuando nos decimos
realmente a nosotros mismos sí Esto es
lo que vamos a mandar
exactamente sí es verdad que en los
conciertos Es realmente Rock porque
también tenemos este lado que yo cultivo
que es que somos animadores somos
bufones y la gente quiere pan Circo y
que le entretenga han pagado mucho
dinero por su entrada quieren saltar
quieren sudar quieren disfrutar si no se
sientan van a ver un concierto de música
clásica o de otra cosa pero cuando la
gente va a ver nuestro concierto quieren
divertirse incluso cuando yo iba a ver
un concierto cuando era joven pagas
mucho dinero por una entrada de
concierto has ahorrado si la banda es
aburrida si se miran los pies y no dan
las gracias si no entran en contacto con
el público no es lo mismo ya sabes y es
verdad que a veces tenemos el debate en
la banda entre hacer música de calidad
en el escenario y ser buenos o saltar
por todos lados y cantar un poco menos
bien y de hecho yo prefiero cantar un
poco peor porque no es un CD la gente se
habrá olvidado a los dos segundos Pero
en cambio la gente no se olvida cuando
vas a verlos entre el público
Muchas gracias muchas gracias hasta
luego
[Música]